mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi samedi et
dimanche en une semaine le château de
Versailles a été évacué six fois à cause
de multiples alertes à la bombe B on
était en cours tout simplement au
château de versaill et à ce momentl on a
entendu une une sonnerie nous demandant
de de sortir puis le personnel est venu
n nous indiquer la sortie et donc on a
on a suivi on a suivi le monde en fait
on avait fait même des
pronostics pour savoir si notre cours
allait justement durer toute la J ou si
on allait être évacué avant donc voilà
des multiples alertes à la bombe posté
via le site
moncommissariat.fr face à cette
situation les touristes sont contraints
de s'adapter c'est dommage pour les gens
qui viennent de loin nous ça va on est à
Paris donc voilà le policier nous a dit
que ça devrait rouvrir dans 2h de 3h
donc je pense pas qu'on va attendre mais
on va réessayer les autres jours et on
verra oui nous sommes des touristes nous
venons de Croatie nous sommes là pour
quelques jours et nous attendons pour
pouvoir aller à l'intérieur du château
de
Versailles nous avions entendu les
nombreuses alertes à la bombe sur
internet le château ouvre et ferme ouvre
et ferme mais nous allons attendre et
nous serons heureux si nous pouvons
rentrer à
l'intérieur je ne vais pas pouvoir aller
au château de Versailles maintenant
parce que j'ai une réservation pour
aller visiter la Tour Effel mais je vais
peut-être revenir demain des évacuations
qui ne profitent pas au tourisme en
cette fin de haute maisison le château
accueille entre 10000 et 15000 visiteurs
par jour les conséquences elles
arriveront si l'information est
tellement diffusé notamment à l'étranger
que certains se disent on va annuler
notre voyage ou le reporter il y a un
certain nombre de commerçants autour du
château qui nous disent que ils
regrettent parce que par exemple ils ont
perdu une clientèle habitué à faire des
visites particulières au château des
choses comme ça
selon le ministre de la Justice ces
fausses alertes ont donné lieu à
l'ouverture de 22 enquêtes judiciaires
la sanction peut aller jusqu'à 2 ans de
prison et 30000 € d'amende et pour la
première fois en 8 jours pas
d'évacuation du château de Versailles
aujourd'hui normal le site est fermé au
public comme tous les
lundis